不然回到多数的版牙Dodo的Spanish没想到吧，我们居然这么快又更新了。没办法呀，西班牙竞决赛啦，ole！
那么不管是喜不喜欢足球的朋友们，大家其实都应该已经有所耳闻吧，西班牙将在明天，西班牙这边的时间是晚上21点，与阿根廷进行世界杯决赛的争夺。
那么今天我们就来聊聊西班牙和阿根廷。那么秉持着我们节目的一贯作风，我们也并不是单纯从足球的角度来出发而是更多的来聊一下这两个国家、这两个民族之间的历史渊源、恩怨情仇。
当然，跟足球还是会时不时的对照一下。那好，那现在我们就开始吧。
你都知道，南美国家大多数都曾经是西班牙的殖民地，所以他们今天其实大多数都说的西班牙语嘛，那么阿根廷也无例外。
但是阿根廷的独立，就是他们所谓的1810年的5月革命，其实并不是一场我们想象中的拉美的原住民反抗欧洲殖民者的战争，而其实是一场西班牙以后代的土身白人。
他们被称为Glios反抗西班牙本土官僚，他们的这种严格来说是一场白人之间的内奉。
那么阿根廷能够独立其实最直接的原因是西班牙人自己在1808年遭遇了毁灭性的灭国危机。
我们都知道，1808年拿破伦战争，拿破伦的军队入侵了西班牙，强行废除了西班牙国王卡洛斯四世和他的王储非帝南七世，把自己的哥哥约瑟夫波纳巴扶上了西班牙的王位。
当这个消息转转了两年在1810年春天飘扬过海传到了西班牙的海外灵地，阿根廷的布里努斯艾利斯时，当地的土身白人精英就有点懵了。
怎么说，西班牙现在的总督是法国傀儡政权任命的，那我们为什么要听一个中国人比较熟悉的语境来说，就是为什么要听伟军的呢？
于是，在1810年的5月25日，布里努斯艾利斯就成立了他们的自治军政府，也就是我们所说的五月革命。
现在的阿根廷还有很多纪念，就是5月25日的很多广场，什么节日等等。
但是他们很聪明的一点，他们没有立刻宣布独立，而是玩了一个政治手段，他们宣称说我们不服从的是现在法国人扶植的西班牙傀儡政府。
我们建立军政权是为了效忠之前的西班牙正统国王，现在是被囚禁的废蒂南七世，我们是为他敬忠，为他来管理这片土地的。
所以，这在历史上被称为废蒂南七世的假面具，就是阿根廷人带着这个假面具用效忠西班牙国王的借口合法的把那个时候在阿根廷的西班牙总督感谢。
那么当地土生的西班牙白人后裔，也就是阿根廷人，对吧，他们为什么有这个底气敢这么做呢？
其实在1810年5月革命之前有一场关键的序幕战争，这场战争可以说是彻底的摧毁了阿根廷人心理上对他们的宗主国西班牙的崇拜，并且建立了极大的心理优越感。
这种优越感甚至可以说在今天仍然某种程度的影响了阿根廷人对西班牙的观感，这个我们后面会说到。
那就是在1806年和1807年的两次英国人入侵拉普拉塔河的事件。
1806年英国军队进攻布尼诺斯艾利斯，当时的西班牙总督叫索布雷蒙德，他没有抵抗，而是竟然带着国库的财宝丢下了全城的百姓，一路逃到了内陆的克尔多瓦。
现在我们知道克尔多瓦其实是我们西班牙南部，这边雷塞维利亚100多公里的这么一个历史名城，但是其实就跟什么纽约、New York什么的一样。
当时西班牙人到了美洲之后也用很多的西班牙的城市的名字来命名他们在美洲的据点和城市。
阿根廷也有克尔多瓦，比如说哥伦比亚也有马德里，甚至在南美洲也有好几个巴塞罗那等等等等。
那么在西班牙正规军不战而逃的情况下，布尼诺斯艾利斯的土身白人，西班牙的移民，甚至当地的黑人和原住民都自发地组织起来。
在商会的领袖马丁德·阿萨尔，他是一个西班牙人，在他的带领下把当时不可一世的英国军队击退了两次。
最后英国人就只能撤军了，这场胜利让布尼诺斯艾利斯的人产生了一个觉悟说。
英国人打过来的时候，我们在流血牺牲，我们的所谓宗主国西班牙不仅保护不了我们，他们还带着财富临阵脱逃。
反过来说，我们连大英帝国都能够击败，为什么还要听命于一个腐朽的西班牙呢？
那这种老子比宗主国更能打的这种骄傲成为了后来阿根廷人独立的底气。
1814年拿破伦战败被囚禁的西班牙国王菲蒂南七世，也就是当时的王储，菲蒂南七世复卫。
那么阿根廷人本来以为这次我们可以跟西班牙谈谈条件，对吧？
在这段时间当中他们都是实际意义上的自治，然后我们还是说以众于国王的名义来自治的，我们也没有独立。
那我们可以怎么聊一聊条件吧？
但是没想到这位复辟的国王是一个非常极端的顽固专制君主，他一上台就废除了自由主义的宪法并且叫嚣着要派大军来学习美洲彻底镇压当时各个殖民地的叛乱。
那么眼看当时这个假面具，就是废地南七世的假面，阿根廷人是带不下去了。
那么阿根廷人就说，咱们就打开天窗说两话吧。
1816年的7月9日，阿根廷各个省的代表在图谷曼召开国会，正式撕毁了与西班牙的所有扭带宣布建立独立的国家。
随后阿根廷的民族英雄盛马丁，这个我们在小学的历史课，初中的历史课可能都学到过。
Hose de San Martin 他就登场了。
极具讽刺意味的是，盛马丁本人其实是西班牙皇家军队培养出来的精英。
他曾经在西班牙生活了26年，参加过西班牙抵抗拿破轮的塞维利亚战役和败轮战役，并且融获勋章。
但他最终选择背叛西班牙军队回到他的家乡阿根廷，用西班牙人教他的军事技术在治理和庇卢把西班牙殖民军打得落花流水。
在1824年阿亚库乔战役之后，西班牙在南美的统治彻底的土崩瓦解。
但西班牙政府表现出了惊人的傲慢与遲鈍，连续在之后的几十年拒绝承认已经事实存在的阿根廷独立。
直到1859年到1863年间，随着伊沙贝拉二世的比较务实的政府上台，西班牙才在极度不情愿下与阿根廷正式建交。
这长达四十年的拒绝承认让阿根廷社会在立国之初就埋下了深深的反西班牙反殖民的这种民粹心理。
时间来到了十九世纪末二十世纪初，大西洋两岸的这两个国家的国运发生了一次历史性的道错。
1898年，西班牙在美西战争当中惨败，丧失了古巴、波多利戈和菲律宾等这些它最后的海外殖民地，被历史上称为九巴一带的灾难。
这一重窗不仅宣告了西班牙帝国的彻底终结，更引发了其国内深层的政治与经济危机。
为了在丧失领土的地缘废墟上重新建立民族自信，那么西班牙的知识界与政界开始转向他们所谓的建构一种新西班牙性。
在探讨这些说西班牙语的国家，之前是一个大帝国，现在变成了很多独立的国家，他们之间的共同性，西班牙已经不是他们的宗主国了，
但是在这些国家当中，西班牙如何能够继续发挥影响力作为一个领导者而存在？
就是试图通过文化语言的上面的共同性以及移民来重塑对说西班牙语的美洲的精神影响力。
那么与此同时，大洋彼岸的阿根廷正处于其历史上的黄金时代。
阿根廷凭借他肥沃的潘帕斯草原，我们说到阿根廷都是潘帕斯雄鹰，
潘帕斯其实是阿根廷一片非常大的一个大平原，他们当时的自由主义的陷阵框架以及先一步融入全球贸易体系的农牧产品出口，
那么阿根廷一跃就成为了全球最附属的国家之一，被称为南美洲的希望。
那么为了填补在阿根廷广贸国土上的劳动力短缺，阿根廷政府也推行了极具吸引力的开放移民政策，
就跟可能当时某个时期的美国，今天可能也是差不多。
那么在这样一种此消彼长的情形之下，从1895年到1914年的20年间，在阿根廷的西班牙僑民人数翻了四倍，
这些源源不断的跨洋移民绝大多数来自西班牙北部的加利西亚地区以及加拿利群岛。
西班牙国内当时落后的农业生产方式，农村土地的碎片化以及深重的贫穷，
以及为了逃避在北非战场浮兵役的那些恐惧，
驱使着无数的年轻的西班牙农民踏上了漫长的大西洋航线。
直到1910年阿根廷纪念他五月革命的百年国庆的时候，
阿根廷全国已经有十分之一的人是出生在西班牙的。
布里诺斯艾利斯聚集了极其庞大的加利西亚移民群体，
被称为加利西亚以外最大的加利西亚城市。
在阿根廷的语境当中，甚至至今还把西班牙人统称为Gasegos。
如果是阿根廷口音就是Gasegos，
那么在这个词，在当时的语境之下，
就是有点像那种像巴老，巴子那种调侃。
那么这种人口重构迅速的就消解了在独立战争初期两国之间的地缘的疏离感，
因为变成一种你中有我，我中有你的，这么一种情形对吧，有很多西班牙人。
当时你现在有十分之一的阿根廷国民其实是西班牙人，
那么通过这种血缘的混杂与在劳动力关系上的捆绑，
这两个国家被捏合成了一个可以说是同呼吸共命运的一个生命共同体。
人口的深度流动不可避免的在社会文化的每一个角落都会留下印记。
而足球则是这批移民在一国重塑认同宣泄情感的最完美的方式。
在1920年代，阿根廷足球开始通过他们叫做远航的友谊赛开启于旧大陆的首次高规格的体育文明碰撞。
其中最耀眼的一篇，莫过于1925年博卡青年队所进行的长达128天的欧洲巡回赛。
在1925年2月4号，博卡青年队达成福尔摩萨号邮轮跨越大西洋，
在长达22天的航行当中，球员们就只能在狭窄的甲板上进行基础的体能训练。
此行共有17名球员，其中12人来自博卡青年队的本队，
另外5人则是作为强力内援所引进的阿根廷其他俱乐部的球星。
值得一提的是，随行人员当中还包括一位自费前往的，
他是一位布伊诺斯艾利斯的一位公正人，
他的名字叫做Vittoriano Gaffarena，外号叫做Dodo.。
他不仅在旅途中为球员们充当理聊师、按摩师和后勤管理员，
更由于他亲近家产、支持球队的热沉，被球员们惯疑。
Hugado Numero doce就是第12名球员这个外号。
那么从此就开启了世界足球史上著名的所谓的第12人，
这个球迷文化，就是球迷就是球队的第12名球员对吧，
就是由这个Dodo这个人开始的。
当博卡青年队来到了西班牙打他的第一场比赛，
在哪里呢？就在加利西亚，因为阿根廷都是加利西亚人嘛，
他在加利西亚的Viggo，他以3比1击败了赛尔塔队。
随后博卡青年队遗失马德里在大都会球场，
那是那个时候的大都会球场，不是现在新的万达的大都会球场。
2比1击败马德里竞技，随后在查马丁球场1比0击败皇家马德里。
在对阵皇马的比赛当中，阿根廷球员Garmelo Bosso在攻入置身一球之后，
甚至跑向主席台，向看台上的西班牙国王阿芳索13世，
质疑了一个非常夸张的类似于舞台上的那种鞠躬礼。
可以看得出这个南美洲的平民对欧洲的王室其实是不怎么放在眼里的。
5天之后，他们又1比0占胜了当时马德里的另一支球队，
现在已经没有了，叫做Societa himnastica，就是体操协会。
这么一个队也是1比0。
就此完成了在马德里对西班牙三支球队的全胜横扫。
阿根廷足球原本是带有农列的英国殖民色彩。
在二十世纪初，足球在布伊诺斯艾利斯，
其实是由英国僑民铁路工程师和圣安德鲁斯这些英式学校所主导的运动。
这点其实跟西班牙差不多。
西班牙其实它最早的足球俱乐部也是到这边来开矿的一些英国公司，
在我们这边一个叫Wellba的地方来建立的一个足球俱乐部。
他们的风格就比较强调体能纪律，
打的是长船冲掉以及那种fairplay的这种声势风度的这种规则。
然而随着南欧移民的子弟大量的涌入潘帕斯平原的一些平民区的小镇，
足球开始在街头巷尾流传起来。
而那种被称为他们叫Bodrello。
Bodrello就是小马嘛。
Bodrello其实字面上来说就是好像骑着小马的那种人。
那么在这些空地上面开始玩起了一些完全不同于在正式足球场的草地上踢的那种足球。
足球在阿根廷完成了一次深刻的本土化的重构。
那么这种全新的风格被称为La Nuestra。
La Nuestra其实就是ours，就是我们的。
那意思就是我们的风格吧。
大家想到那个意大利的黑手党不是他们曾经有一只叫做La Cosa Nuestra，
就是我们的事业，那其实是差不多的意思。
那么它就是摒弃了英式的那种硬朗与机械的这种风格，
将阿根廷他们传统的那种比如说探戈的韵律，
比如说在街头生存所需要的这种欺骗性的假动作，
细腻的盘带以及急剧个人创造力的进行发挥，
融入了足球当中。
在伯卡青年队的巡演大圣之后，
西班牙的舆论对伯卡青年队所展现出来的激战术风格。
赶到了巨大的震惊。
当时的西班牙足球呢，
就算我刚才说的也是普遍深受英式打法的这种直接与刚猛的影响，
我们在上一期的足球节目当中也谈到过一嘴，
而阿根廷人带来的这一种带球的粘制性空间的创造力，
以及那种杂耍式的短传渗透，
被当时的卡斯蒂亚体育报的媒体预围。
为绿音场上的杂技团马拉巴利斯达。
那么这种初次的碰撞不仅打破了西班牙人对前殖民地。
好像是一种未开化的野蛮人的这种成就的认知，
更在深层唤醒了西班牙本土对技巧型足球的狂热追求。
所以说西班牙今天的迪基达尔可能他的最早的源头。
其实也是来自于阿根廷的。
好，我们把时间拉到二十世纪的四十年代，
那么在那个时候，大西洋两岸的地缘政治又发生了更加戏剧性的逆转。
西班牙在经历了惨烈的内战之后，
我们知道就是大概在1935年到1939年之间，
是弗朗哥政府赢得了内战，
确立了弗朗哥的法西斯独裁统治，
并且在第二次世界大亚战当中，
虽然它是没有正式参战，
但是由于它的意识形态，
它事实上是与周星国保持了同盟关系。
那么在二战结束之后，
胜利的中国集团就对西班牙实施了。
严厉的在政治上与经济上的孤立，
将其排除在联合国以及美国援助欧洲的马歇尔计划之外，
那么直接导致了西班牙国内的经济崩溃，
陷入了严重的物资溃发，
与他们所谓的Aniós de Ambre，
就是饥饿年代这么一个时代当中。
而此时的阿根廷，
则由他们的民粹主义领袖还Domingo Beron执政，
我们都知道这个Beron将军，对吧，
他推行的这个第三条道路的外交路线，
并试图通过掌控全球战后粮食紧缺的这么一个契机，
因为阿根廷不是产粮嘛，
他的那个大草原是种粮食非常好的地方，
那他掌握了粮食就能够提升阿根廷的国际地位。
那在这一背景之下，
阿根廷与西班牙就达成了著名的叫做。
贝隆弗朗哥协定，
这一个协定主要是由阿根廷贸易促进会主导实施的，
那么根据在1948年签订的最终协议，
阿根廷将在1948年到1951年期间，
每年向西班牙提供高达3.5亿币所的循环信贷，
4年的信贷总额达到17.5亿币所。
这一信贷额度，
被用于购买阿根廷的浓穆物资，
尤其是数百万吨的小麦，牛肉，皮革和油料，
就是阿根廷说我有钱，我借钱给你，
这个协专款专用，你要用来买我的东西，
OK，那这个协定就彻底的解救了被美英禁运，
而没有办法进口粮食的弗朗哥政权，
使西班牙内部免于因为饥荒而崩溃，
阿根廷为西班牙提供了4年的基本粮食安全保障，
那么在阿根廷国内他的官方宣传，
他是说我们是同胞，
血农于水，所以说我们要反驳我们的兄弟国家。
那同时，西班牙也承诺向阿根廷交付传播，
仿制机械，化学品，以及一些军工，
防务方面的物资来充底西班牙在西方的部分的债权。
那么这也在很大的程度上缓解了，
阿根廷他着急重粮食，
而在工业化的过程中造成的，
资本品的紧缺，
但是因为西班牙自身的工业，
也是在账后比较的雕臂，
所以说在武器，
这些比较高价值的工业品的承诺，
其实普朗格政府到最后是没有能够完全兑现这个协议的。
值得一提的是，阿根廷当时他不仅在物资上拯救了。
处于饥饿边缘的西班牙人口，
在联合国大会上极力反对对西班牙的制裁，
充当了普朗格政权，
在联合国上可以说最坚定的一个地缘政治的避风港。
那么刚才说到这个贝隆政府，
其实如果你不了解他们的话，
你至少也肯定听说过贝隆夫人，
对吧，他就是在1947年那个时候阿根廷的第一夫人，
被阿根廷人亲切的称为Evita，
那么我记得在好像是1996年的时候吧，
麦当娜曾经主演过一部影片，
当时也是非常的轰动啊，
就叫做Evita，贝隆夫人。
那么有麦当娜演这位贝隆夫人，
他的这个主题曲啊，
阿根廷别为我哭泣，
我相信今天至今仍然是快智人口的名曲。
那么1947年6月呢，
贝隆夫人出访欧洲，
首战就是马德里，
那么这次旅行呢，
被称为Hila de Argo Elis,。
彩虹之旅。
弗朗哥政权调动了前所未有的国家机器，
与以最高规格的接待，
数以十万计的马德里市民。
被动员走上街头，
挥舞着西阿两国国旗，
高呼着
Franco Beron e un solo corazón,。
就是
Franco Beron,。
两个人就是同一颗心，
对吧，就是两心相通吧，
可以这么说。
那么在西班牙王宫的阳台上，
贝隆夫人，
向成千上万的西班牙底层民众，
发表了他著名的那种，
具有民粹色彩的演讲，
宣称他是为了和平，
工作,
和粮食而到访西班牙的，
而弗朗哥也亲自为他。
佩戴了西班牙的最高荣誉，
伊沙贝拉天主教女王大十字勋章。
然而,
在这一层充满激情的。
政治同盟表象之下，
却暗流涌动，
有着非常复杂的阶级。
与心理冲突。
根据Eva Beron,。
事后向其私人发行师等亲信的披露，
他对弗朗哥，
以及弗朗哥的夫人，
Garmin Bolo,。
充满了一种
比译与排斥。
他直言不讳的说，
弗朗哥身形矮小，
然后挺着个肚子，
举止笨拙，
一点没有领袖的英雄气概，
反而像一个在阿根廷小镇上。
卖烤鸡的杂货铺老板，
他是这么说的。
那么更深层的冲突，
其实是来自于阶级立场。
Evita,
她出身于阿根廷底层，
她是以穷人，
他们叫做Descamisade，
就是连衬衫都穿不起的人，
她的,
以这种穷人的守护者自居的。
那么她非常反感，
弗朗哥的第一夫人，
Garmin Bolo,。
她那种居高临下的，
贵族式的傲慢，
在很多次的私下交谈当中，
Garmin Bolo对西班牙工人阶级，
非常的贬低，
将其统称为在内战中赋予顽抗的。
Rohos,
就是红军，
很讽刺的是今天西班牙国家，
对他们的外号，
就叫La Roja,。
红衣军。
因为那么当时，
弗朗哥刚刚赢得了内战，
在内战当中，
弗朗哥打败的就是左派的，
那么说，
红色的共产主义的这些人。
那么,
Eva对此,
就进行了冷潮热风，
所以说，
这两位国家的第一夫人，
在关于劳工权力
和慈善事业的理解上，
发生了，
可以说是严重的思想交火。
所以说，
即使两国在政治蜜月的最高峰，
庇隆主义的那种，
激进的民粹色彩，
与弗朗哥主义的保守威权，
他们之间仍然存在着，
不可调和的意识形态的红钩。
说到这里，
大家肯定要说了，
这个庇隆主义，
不也是一种右翼民粹主义吗？
那么,
而且他跟弗朗哥政府，
走得这么近，
为什么还会有，
这方面的，
这种冲突呢？
其实呢，
关于,
庇隆主义，
究竟是属于左派，
还是右派，
在政治学和历史学界，
一直是一个非常有争议的一个课题。
虽然说，
战后的阿根廷的，
庇隆政府与西班牙的，
弗朗哥独裁政权，
走得非常近，
但其实并不意味着，
庇隆主义可以被简单的，
划规为一种，
右派的意识形态。
他可以说是一个，
政治上的变色龙，
或者说一个，
民粹主义的大熔炉，
同时包含了，
极左和极右的元素，
所以说我们刚才说，
庇隆主义他的外交政策，
叫做第三条道路。
那么这个可能，
就是单说一期，
可能都有余，
这里最多就只能简单的提一下，
因为庇隆本身，
他是军人出身，
对吧,
所以说他是一个强人统治，
有军队背景，
然后他又是一个，
具有右翼法西斯主义的那种，
核心特征，
就是反对阶级斗争，
主张由国家出面，
来调和资本家和工人，
等等,
那么庇隆政府，
可以说是完美的实践了这一点，
他既支持工会，
又保护，
资产阶级，
以此来打压真正的，
左翼的共产党和社会党，
同时他也有非常强烈的，
民族主义，
与保守的天主教价值观，
那么这跟弗朗格政府，
也是不谋而合的，
但如果他只是单纯的，
右翼独裁的话，
他是不可能在阿根廷底层，
拥有长达半个多世纪，
甚至至今都被人怀念的，
这种生命力的，
那么他其实在，
经济和社会政策上，
又是极度偏左的，
他的核心口号之一呢，
就是社会正义，
Whose DCLismo,。
在庇隆和庇隆夫人，
他们在位的期间，
他们大幅的提升了，
工人的工资，
立法保障，
8小时工作制，
贷薪休假，
养老金，
失业保险，
等等的这一系列，
来巩固他们在，
社会劳动阶层当中，
他们的支持率，
那么同时，
他们的经济民族主义呢，
也把,
很多原来由英国人，
控制的铁路，
法国人控制的港口，
以及电话电力等，
公共服务，
进行了国有化。
同时,
我们刚才说，
说到的Evita，
他是说，
自己是连衬衫都穿不起的，
这些Descamisaro,。
赤平阶层的圣母，
他通过建立庞大的福利基金，
直接向穷人发放物资，
建造医院，
学校等等，
这种对精英阶层的仇视，
和对底层的煽动，
其实也具有强烈的，
左翼革命色彩。
我们看一看，
今天的美国呢，
似乎,
跟那个时候，
是不是有一点不谋而合？
所以说呢，
胡安贝龙，
他自己对，
贝龙主义的定义，
是他刚刚，
我们刚才所说的，
社会正义对吧，
他公开宣称，
这是一条，
第三条道路，
既反对美式的资本主义，
又反对苏式的共产主义。
那么在冷战的背景之下呢，
他既利用左翼的工人力量，
来对抗国内的传统的，
地主精英，
和英美资本，
同时呢，
又利用了右翼的军队，
和教会，
来镇压真正的共产主义革命，
这种两头讨好的，
民粹主义策略，
导致,
一个政治上的万花筒。
那最后呢，
提一句，
在1974年,
贝隆去世之后，
贝隆主义者的阵营，
彻底分裂成了，
适不量力的两个极端，
这个强人，
不在了之后，
就没有人再能够，
把这两者统一起来了。
其中的左翼贝隆主义，
叫做Mondoneros,。
发展成了激进的，
马克思主义城市游机队，
他们呢，
就是试图通过暴力革命，
来建立一个社会主义的阿根廷，
同时呢，
右翼的贝隆主义，
他们被称为3A党，
不是3K党，
叫Dripplea,。
发展成了一个残酷的，
极右翼的暗杀组织，
甚至他联合军队，
对左翼的阿根廷人，
进行了血腥的屠杀。
这个以后，
我们要是有时间呢，
或者说，
找到一些跟西班牙相关的，
一些联系呢，
我们可以单独的再说一起。
好的,
那么我们说回来，
刚才所说的这个，
弗朗哥和贝隆的他们的，
这个协议呢，
其实也没有持续多久，
最终,
随着阿根廷自身在1949年，
陷入外汇告急，
与黄金储备枯竭的，
这么一个经济困境，
贝隆政府被迫于当年宣布，
暂停执行这个贝隆弗朗哥协议，
停止向西班牙发放新的信贷和小脉，
那么这场由政治利益和人道救援，
混合而成的大戏，
在给弗朗哥政府叙命之后呢，
最后还是匆匆落幕，
促使西班牙转而寻求冷战铁幕下，
跟美国的在军事和经济上的合作和庇护。
那么在这个时代，
也就是说在阿根廷在政治经济上，
用他们的粮食和资金强力支撑，
西班牙社会不使他遥遥欲墜，
同时在足球世界上的这种反向输出，
也达到了历史性的顶点。
那么最具象征意义的图腾，
就是我们之前在散装西班牙当中，
提到过一嘴的 Alfredo de Stefano di Stefano.。
那么,
di Stefano出身于布伊诺斯埃利斯，
成长于河床队阿根廷的豪门球队，
他在球场上的风格，
是一种覆盖全场的组织能力和一种球商，
非常地高，
具有无与伦比的进球能力，
是典型的我们刚才说到的。
阿根廷Lannoystra风格的极大撑者。
那么他一头经发，
速度也非常的快，
所以被称为金色的狂风Side Rubia，
是不是跟后世的金色轰大机，
克林斯曼是不是有点一举同工之妙。
那么在经历了与哥伦比亚百万富翁队的过渡之后，
这个当时，
你们也可以去听一下我们说到巴萨黄马的那一期节目，
di Stefano最终在巴塞罗那与皇家马德里那场。
极具争议的转会拉鞠战当中，
加门了皇家马德里。
那么,
这一世界彻底重塑了西班牙乃至整个欧洲的足球版图，
di Stefano的加门不仅帮助球队打破了。
巴塞罗那在国内的统治，
更开启了从1956年开始的皇马欧冠五连冠的神话，
将皇家马德里塑造成了二十世纪全球最伟大的一支足球俱乐部。
那么,
如果从我们的这个宏观历史社会学的角度来看，
这个现象其实是完美呼应了。
当时西班牙跟阿根廷两国在资本与文化方面的供需。
一方面，
阿根廷在经济上作为一个施予者，
用他的百万吨的小麦填饱了西班牙人饿着的肚子。
而西班牙人则作为文化与体育方面的吸收者，
将阿根廷最顶尖的体育天才融入自身的国家品牌构建当中，
同时,
弗朗哥政府敏锐的将皇家马德里在欧洲的胜利，
作为其打破外交孤立，
展示新西班牙强国形象的这么一个对外的出窗。
迪斯蒂凡的这位来自阿根廷的移民，
最终也被授予了西班牙国籍，
也代表了西班牙国家队出战。
那么,
西班牙通过足球在文化层面上，
对昔日的殖民地所输送的顶尖的体育力量，
可以说是进行了一个完美的收编与童话。
20世纪下半年，
两国的命运再次步入了一条神奇的平行而错位的轨道。
1975年，独裁者弗朗哥去世，
西班牙在一代政治精英的审慎操作下，
完成了平稳渐进的民主转型。
这个我们之前也说过好几次了，
在《呼安卡罗斯一世》的那几期节目当中，
提到了当时的西班牙的民主转型了，
当时西班牙的民主转型了。
所以说，
他就确定了君主立宪制和现代多党的民主，
并且逐步的融入了欧共体，
实现了经济上的腾飞。
此时此刻，
彼岸的阿根廷却陷入了深重的黑暗。
1955年,
贝隆在其第二任总统任内被政变推翻，
流亡巴拉圭最终定居马德里，
收到了弗朗哥政府逃逃暴力的保护。
而1960年代起，
阿根廷的政局剧烈动荡。
1973年,
贝隆自西班牙流亡地短暂的回国复辟，
但是他事实之后，
国家迅速的再次陷入混乱。
最终在1976年，
爆发了右翼军人政变，
确定了以伯德拉为首的军政府独裁统治。
军政府实施了残酷的肮脏战争，
这个是在历史上非常有名的，
所谓Gera Sucia,。
导致多达3万名左翼青年知识分子，
工会领袖和意见人士，
被失踪，
都不知道到哪去了。
那么这一政治上的温差，
也引发了现代史上第一次大规模的，
阿根廷知识分子，
向西班牙的政治流亡潮。
大量的阿根廷作家，精神分析学家，
导演教授，
以及左翼的活动家纷纷出头。
在语言无障碍，文化同源，
而且刚刚确立自由民主体制的西班牙，
尤其是巴塞罗娜和马德里，
那么就成为了他们最理想的避难所。
到了二十世纪九十年代，
两国的地缘博弈，
从我们之前所说的政治庇护，
也迅速的转向了残酷的资本违略。
1989年,
阿根廷正处于恶性通货膨胀，
与经济崩溃的边缘。
当时新当选的总统卡洛斯·梅内姆，
全面拥抱华盛顿共识，推行极端的私有化改革。
阿根廷几乎所有的核心国家基础设施，
包括电话网络、电力、贡水、铁路、航空，
乃至于国家的经济支柱，
阿根廷国营石油公司，
就是YPF,
全部被打包推向了国际资本市场进行私有化的变迈。
大家是不是听得很熟悉，
差不多也是同样的时间在苏联解体之后，
其实发生了也是非常接近的一件事情。
那么当时已经融入欧盟，
积累了比较丰厚的资本实力，
并且急于开拓海外版图的西班牙企业，
凭借着他们同文同种的优势，
在这场私有化的陶贴盛宴当中，
充当了最凶猛的补识者。
这一波西班牙资本的西征，
在拉美经济史中被带有讽刺意味的称为。
La Segunda Conquista,。
第二次征服，
第一次征服就是西班牙殖民者，
带着监传力炮去征服他们的原住民。
第二次是西班牙公司带着他们的欧洲资本。
来收购这些当地的国有资产。
那么其中最大最震撼的一笔交易，
就是发生于1999年西班牙能源巨头，
通过OPA公开邀约，
就是以高达148.55亿美元的价格，
一举吞并了阿根廷，
最大也是他们在民族情感当中最神圣的国家企业，
也就是YPF阿根廷国家石油公司。
你就想一下，
来了一个外国企业把中石油中石化给收购了，
大概就是这么一个意思。
那么这一个举动令阿根廷超越震动，
YPF不仅是一家石油公司，
它是阿根廷现代工业化进程和资源主权的化身。
在这场资本狂潮当中，
西班牙电信，也就是Delefonica，
垄断了阿根廷南部的通信网，
西班牙国家电力公司Endesa，
控制了布里诺斯，艾利斯，
以及周边省份的电力供应。
刚才我们所说到的西班牙石油巨头Repsol，
则掌控了阿根廷所有的油气开采与练化网络。
这种几乎买下整个阿根廷经济命脉的扩张，
在阿根廷民众心中激起了一种复杂的心理防线。
一方面，西班牙的资本确实带来了服务的现代化，
以及基础设施的技术升级，
但是更重要的是另一方面，
阿根廷人眼睁睁的看着自己国家的战略资源，
源源不断的向昔日的宗主国输送利润。
地缘层面的民粹主义怨恨，
在水面下慢慢的积聚起来。
就在西班牙资本疯狂地在阿根廷工程略地的同时，
阿根廷人則在西班牙最神圣的足球殿堂里。
完成了一场肉体和精神层面的反向征服。
1978年,
玛里奥·肯佩斯带领阿根廷国家队奪得世界盃冠军，
那些世界盃就在阿根廷本土进行的。
那么这位身材高大，求风刚稳，
但是又不失潘帕斯临性的前锋，
他当时就是在西班牙的瓦伦西亚俱乐部，
连续地奪得了西甲的精靴，
并且带领球队获得欧洲优胜者盃的胜利。
肯佩斯他的成功也彻底拉开了西甲联赛。
长达30年的阿根廷化的大幕。
1982年,
刚刚在阿根廷国内成长为一代球王的，
大家一起来，
列宫马拉多纳，
对，就是马拉多纳，
他以当时创纪录的身架，
加盟了巴塞罗纳俱乐部。
虽然马拉多纳在巴塞的经历，
因为他肝炎，
断腿,
以及与俱乐部高层的冲突，
可以说是并不是非常完美，
但他随后还在我们这边塞维利亚踢了一年，
以及他在每一次西班牙国家得比当中，
也都展现出的超凡记忆，
都在西班牙球迷群体当中，
剥下了近乎神格化的崇拜的种子。
这一时期的文化上的对比，
是非常具有戏剧张力的。
西班牙的金融家、企业家，
坐在布伊诺斯艾利斯的大楼里，
签署着资本收购的协议，
在经济上再次殖民阿根廷，
但是西班牙的普通民众，
每个礼拜天都会到诺坎普，
皮斯环，向着阿根廷的球王欢呼。
那么这种经济上被掠夺感，
与体育上的征服感，
在两国民众的潜意识当中，
达成了某种平衡，
一种补偿机制，
也进一步的固化了西班牙跟阿根廷关系，
那种相爱相杀的咬合的状态。
时间来到了二十一世纪，
天平再次发生了剧烈的摇摆。
2001年底，由于长期推行新自由主义政策。
和本币与美元的硬性挂钩，
阿根廷又又又爆发了严重的经济危机。
阿根廷政府就采取了限制居民提取银行存款，
这种策略使得本币瞬间贬值百分之七十以上。
失业率飙升至百分之二十五以上，
就会治安彻底失控。
这一灾难引发了空前的方向，
也是完全逆转的二代回流移民潮。
我们之前说到了，
很多的阿根廷人都是当年西班牙的移民，
那么二十世纪上半夜有数百万人的西班牙人移民阿根廷，
这些人的子孙后代普遍就合法的拥有了双重国籍，
或者至少能够依法申请西班牙国籍。
那么为了逃避母国的绝对贫困和毫无希望的未来，
数十万受过高等教育的阿根廷年轻一代，
他们当中有很多都是医生、工程师、学者、艺术家等等，
纷纷取出组备那种破旧的西班牙护照，
买了一张飞往马德里的单程机票。
然而这批逆向的移民在西班牙的社会遭遇，
其实却是充满了幻灭与挣扎。
首先是社会地位的断崖式下跌，
许多在阿根廷拥有硕士学位，
原本属于中产阶级的专业人士，
在马德里却只能从事餐饮服务，
底层的文书、看护这种体力劳动，
面临着巨大的心理落差，
其次是那种亲近但又不一样的身份排斥。
虽然他们说着同一种语言，
但在西班牙本土的语境当中，
他们却是面临着一种被边缘化的尴尬。
西班牙本土在经历了数十年的欧洲化之后，
他的社会心态早已对美洲大陆的那种。
好像大家是自己人的温情默默，
转向了欧洲式的冷漠与务实。
而这种民间的双方的不信任，
怀疑与怨恨，
最终在国家主权层面和战略资源的领域。
爆发了一次毁灭性的地缘政治的地震。
那就是2012年，
YPF阿根廷国家石油公司的国有化危机，
因为自2010年起，
YPF的技术人员在巴塔格尼亚地区，
勘探发现了世界级的超大型液炎油气田，
叫做巴加摩尔达斯牛。
他潜在的储量估算，
可以说是高达228亿桶的原油，
那么这一战略性发现，
彻底改变了博弈的筹码。
2012年4月16日，
时任阿根廷的总统，
是一个非常民粹主义的总统，
叫做Kristina Fernandez,。
突然发表了全国性的电视讲话，
我还记得当时在新闻上看到那个讲话，
我还觉得，
Kristina年轻的时候应该是个美女。
那么她当时就在电视上讲话，
指责西班牙的Repsol集团，
自1999年收购YPF以来，
只顾追求短期的高额分红，
长期对西班牙本土勘探投资不足，
导致阿根廷从一个能源出口国，
退化到需要消耗巨额外汇，
来进口能源的这么一个国家。
那么Kristina Fernandez就宣布,。
阿根廷联邦政府强行中职与Repsol的合作，
通过立法程序，
将它持有的51%的阿根廷国家石油公司的股份，
与强制的国有化收回。
那么此话一出，
在马德里引发了排山倒海般的愤怒。
时任西班牙首相的Mariano Rajoy，
这个Rajoy前几天还出了个楼子，
就在西班牙对法国的办决赛之前，
他接受了一个采访，
他说法国队有一只水平非常高的球队，
可惜没有法国人。
那么这句话一出来，
就是一个典型的种族歧视，
因为法国队都是黑人，
但是人家是法国人，
那就成了一个外交世界了，
你作为一个前首相，
说出这种话，
在欧洲，在欧盟内部，
特别是跟法国之间，
引起了一个比较大的丑闻。
OK，话说回来，
然后当时所领导的西班牙保守党政府，
可以说是误伤其类吧，
他就怒斥，
此举是对西方资本的公然掠夺，
违反了国际投资保护协定，
那么西班牙政府召见了阿根廷的大使，
甚至威胁要在欧盟框架当中切断。
对阿根廷的最惠我待遇。
一直到2014年这件事情，
虽然阿根廷政府强行收回了YPF的股份，
但是由于缺乏国际资本和技术，
来让它能够独立的开发，
刚才所说的这个业延器，
急于重返国际资本市场的阿根廷政府，
最终不得不做出妥协，
同意向西班牙石油公司Ripso，
支付价值50亿美元的十年期政府国债，
作为和解补偿金，
双方指了在世界银行，
解决投资争端国际中心的国际仲裁诉讼，
而没有参与和解的其他的股东，
比如Peterson集团和伊顿公园，
就把这个诉讼转到了美国法院，
来提起诉讼。
2013年9月,。
美国纽约联邦法官Loretta Breska，
判决裁定阿根廷政府必须向这些少数股东支付。
高达161亿美元的赔偿金与利息，
那么这个判决使得当年，
Christina Fernandez政府,。
鲁莽的将YPF收归国有的这个行为，
至今仍然在给阿根廷的财政，
套上了一个沉重的架索。
在此之后，
地缘历史的演变，
其实也并没有终止，
反而在现今政治光谱极端风化的背景下，
演变成了更具个人戏剧性的外交风暴。
就在2024年的5月，
阿根廷新当选的极右翼总统哈维尔米雷，
出访西班牙，
但是他这次却并不是一次官方的国事访问，
而是高调参加西班牙极右翼的在野党Vox，
在马德里举办的所谓的。
欧洲活力24的政治集会。
在这次的集会演讲当中，
米雷以及一贯的狂野的政治风格，
大家都知道，
都看到过他当时在阿根廷举起他的那个电剧，
对吧,
他猛烈的抨击了当时的西班牙，
也是现在的西班牙首相Bedro Sanchez，
他所倡导的民族社会主义路线，
甚至他在不提名的这种情况下，
公开的讽刺了Sanchez的妻子Begonia Gomez，
涉嫌卷入贪腐和影响力的交易，
称他为一个肮脏腐败的女人。
这个Begonia Gomez的案子，
到现在还在继续，
就在这个礼拜，
好像他还是被西班牙的大法官，
什么没收了护照等等，
以后我们可以，
大家感兴趣的话，
也可以聊一下。
那么这个言论，
当然是一枚重磅炸弹，
那首先是西班牙的激烈反应，
Sanchez政府就认为，
米勒的言论是对西班牙国家主权，
民主制度和首相尊严的，
不可容忍的一种侮辱。
西班牙外交大臣，
Hosemane Avales,。
宣布立刻无限期，
召回西班牙驻阿根廷大使。
然后呢，
是外交级别上的永久降级，
2024年5月21日，
由于米勒强硬拒绝道歉，
反而连续通过社交媒体发布言论，
成Sanchez为软弱傲慢的社会主义者等等。
西班牙内阁会议正式通过决议，
宣布永久撤销西班牙驻布伊诺斯艾利斯的大使职务，
使两国的外交关系，
事实上降到了由临时代办这种维持的非常低级别。
那么米勒与Sanchez这种冲突，
绝不是个人之间的口舌之快，
而是拉美的右翼民粹主义，
大家知道米勒被称为阿根廷特朗普，
对吧,
与欧洲传统的社会民主主义之间，
在意识形态上的深层裂痕。
阿根廷县政府，
试图彻底斩断与传统西欧进步主义政治轴心的这种链接，
转而与西班牙本土的激进保守势力，
就是吉尤伊德沃克斯进行跨国的合作。
这就标志着，
曾经有血缘和共同历史支撑的西班牙阿根廷官方的关系，
在意识形态两级分化的时代，
已经脆弱到了非常容易，
因为政客的个人言论而彻底撕裂的地步。
但当大西洋两岸的政治关系，
在克里斯蒂娜和拉赫尔、米勒和桑切斯，
他们之间的轮番思策下，
坠入冰点的时候，
两国的民众在精神层面的最大公约数，
却由一个身材矮小来自Rossalio的男孩，
奇迹班的维持者，
他就是Leonel Messi。
2000年9月,。
13岁的梅希因为患有生长激素缺乏症，
而且阿根廷国内的俱乐部无力支付他每月高昂的治疗费用。
在他父亲的陪伴下，
飘扬过海来到巴塞罗纳俱乐部进行视讯。
这个时间点，
大家注意是具有非常深刻的历史隐喻。
梅希全家的这个班到西班牙来居住，
在物理上是完美的契合了2001年阿根廷金融崩溃爆发这个时间点。
无数的阿根廷中产阶级通过逆向的移民逃往西班牙，
我们刚才提到的这个社会浪潮，
而梅希实质上就是那十几万，
流向西班牙寻找深入和未来尊严的阿根廷人的孩子当中的一员。
那么在巴塞罗纳著名的拉马西，
清迅营梅希接受了最严苛最现代化的欧洲足球战术与生理科学的塑造。
他在这里不但是在相当程度上治疗了他的生长激素缺乏阵，
梅希最终也长到了1米70这样的一个身高，
不然的话他可能就要停留在这么一个大概1米3级1米4级这样的高度了。
他在这里成长成为了足球史上的不适之才，
并且为巴塞奪得了包括四座欧冠10次西甲冠军在内的无数荣誉。
那么从文化社会学的角度上来看，
梅希也就成为了西阿两国百年足球纠葛中最完美的双向文化结晶。
梅希骨子里保持了阿根廷街头那种最纯粹的Bordrero的精神，
他那种不可预测的重心晃动以及在极小的空间内的精妙盘带。
超越了足球对实用主义的这么一种使用，
而是达到了一种近乎艺术的高度。
同时他又融入了巴塞罗那传控足球Digitagar的高度的组织性，
空间几何感和战术上的服从性。
在梅希漫长的职业生涯当中，
西班牙足协曾经尝试多次游说劝说起加入西班牙的国家队，
与他在拉马西亚的队友哈维·伊涅斯塔一起并肩作战。
大家想象一下那是那应该是怎样的一个黄金一代。
然而梅希每一次都给出了斩钉劫铁的拒绝，
他坚定的表示他的未来或许在巴塞罗那，
但是他的灵魂、他的球衣永远只属于阿根廷。
那么正是因为这种坚守，
让阿根廷人将其视为最纯粹的民族英雄。
对于西班牙球迷而言，
他们见证了梅希从一个羞雀的13岁的少年成长成为绿营厂上的主宰。
在诺坎普，加太罗尼亚和西班牙球迷每周都在高呼他的名字。
2026年，无论是在美国新泽西大都会人寿提长将上演的世界杯巅峰对决，
还是在之后筹备中的美欧冠军杯菲奈利西马。
那么西班牙与阿根廷这两只站在世界之巅的球队，
它背后都流传着长达百年的绿营厂上的基因交换。
那么刚才就提到了有很多的阿根廷人，
因为他祖上是西班牙人，
所以他自动拥有双重国籍或者可以申请西班牙国籍。
也说到了西班牙族协曾经多次游说梅希加入西班牙国籍，
但是梅希都拒绝了。
其实在阿根廷与西班牙足球交織的历史当中，
像这样拥有双重国籍，
并且面临为美国效力这样抉择的著名球员是非常多的，
因为阿根廷曾经是西班牙的殖民地，
所以说很多人就在出身或者在他履席之后，
不久就自然的拥有了西班牙国籍。
那么其中几个最著名的案例，
刚才我们说到了梅希，
他是双重国籍，
那么如果梅希选择西班牙，
他就可以和哈维、印尼斯塔一起组织一，
可以说是无敌的宇宙舰队，
但是梅希谷子里的阿根廷的认同感非常的强，
为了能够让梅希为阿根廷效力，
阿根廷足球在2004年特意紧急发明了一场。
阿根廷U20对巴拉圭的友谊赛，
大费周章的跨越大西洋把梅希真招过去，
就是为了在国际足连那里永久的锁定他的阿根廷国籍，
因为他只要为国家对出战国，
他就不能够再为其他的国家出战了。
这个就想到今年的西班牙阵容当中的La Borte，
他其实是深于法国，掌于法国，
但是祖上有巴斯克的血统，
但是法国队的主帅德尚，
好像一直对他有一些个人的意见，
所以他虽然多次的进入法国U20的国家队，
甚至是一直担任队长，
但是他从来没有能够为法国的成年的足球队，
国家队效力过哪怕一分钟，
这一分钟可能就可以锁定他的法国国籍，
最后由于他从来没有在法国国家队当中，
哪怕被真招过，
但是没有任何上场时间，
他就斩转的加入了西班牙国家队，
而这次就在半决赛当中淘汰了法国队，
有一点复仇爽具的意思，
OK，把话说回来，
那么梅西他的坚持可以说完美的对应了阿根廷人，
面对西班牙前宗主国这种傲慢与忠诚，
他要在巴塞罗那拿走所有的荣誉和奖项，
但是他的灵魂他捧起大力神碑的时候，
必须是属于阿根廷的。
那么同样的还有尼克帕斯，
他是出身于西班牙的加拿利群岛，
父亲是阿根廷的前国脚，
他完全是在西班牙的足球土壤里孕育出来的，
因为他是黄马清讯出来的，
西班牙族企业也曾经极力的争取他进入西班牙国家队，
但是他最终也是顺从了他祖国的召唤，
坚决的选择了阿根廷国家队，
并且也是入选了斯卡洛尼直教的陈年队。
当然也有不少人是在阿根廷之外，
寻找他的第二政治故乡。
他们往往是在阿根廷寓意不得志，
或是在西班牙找到了最终的职业生涯的辉煌。
比如说我们刚才说到的阿尔弗雷多迪斯蒂法诺，
他出生于布里诺塞利斯，
年轻时也曾经代表阿根廷夺得了1947年的美洲碑。
在转会黄马之后，
由于他在西班牙展现出了统治级的实力，
于1956年正式入籍西班牙。
当时的国际足连规则是允许的，
所以说他从1957年开始代表西班牙国家队出战，
并且打入了23个进球。
这个事情正好是发生在刚才我们说到的阿根廷和西班牙的小脉外交。
和弗朗哥与庇隆政府的政治蜜月期，
阿根廷不但在物质上援助了西班牙，
甚至还为西班牙国家队提供了阿根廷最伟大的天才。
再说一个，
比如马里亚诺贝尔尼亚这名球员，
他是一位土生土长的阿根廷左后卫，
他父亲也曾经是阿根廷的著名球星。
2003年他来到西班牙踢球，
在赫塔飞和马德里竞技的表现非常的强烈，
而最终拥有了西班牙国籍。
2006年德国世界杯前夕，
由于西班牙主力左后卫德尔尔尔诺重伤，
西班牙主帅阿拉古内斯就紧急征召了。
刚刚拿到西班牙国籍的贝尼亚。
他作为西班牙的首发左后卫，
踢满了2006年的世界杯。
那么这两种不同的选择，
可以说是反射出了两种阿根廷人面对西班牙的这两种心态，
梅西他是那种阿根廷人落魄贵族心理的那种体现，
即使你现代的西班牙是一个更加发达的国家，
他带给我了完美的拉马西亚的清讯最好的医疗，
然后向整个欧洲甚至于世界展现自己的舞台，
但是在世界杯，
我仍然是要把荣耀带回布里诺斯艾利斯，
来打破你年老的欧洲对新大陆的这种蔑视。
但是迪斯蒂法诺或者说佩尔尼亚他们的选择，
则展现了西班牙作为宗主国或者说前母国的这种包容与吸纳。
当阿根廷人在本土因为政治动荡，
经济危机或者说内部的竞争而被埋没的时候，
西班牙总是他们那种天然的没有语言障碍的避风港。
西班牙用西甲和国家队的战跑给了他们足球上的才华，
最充分的一个合法化的证明。
记得当时在跟雷雷辽、西班牙和巴西的那一两期节目当中提到了一个叫做。
由巴西作家尼泽森·罗德里格斯提出的叫杂种狗情结，
指的是巴西人面对外国，
尤其是欧美时他自发产生的一种盲目自卑和妄自匪博的那种心态。
那么阿根廷人有没有这种心态呢？
其实在拉丁美洲阿根廷人，尤其是首都布里诺斯·埃利斯的人，
他们自称伯德尼尔，他们的身份认同是，
他们说，币鲁人来自印加，墨西哥人来自阿斯特克，
而阿根廷人来自船上，也就是说他们是欧洲的移民，
他们并不是美洲的土著，阿根廷人的自我身份认同其实是这样的，
他们觉得自己是南美洲的欧洲人，
他有一种在血统上的带有一点可以说是略微种族歧视色彩的白人优越感。
19世纪末之二世世纪初，阿根廷经历了农业报复的黄金时代，
同时伴随着对本土原住民的残酷的倾角，
以及随后迎来的排山岛海般的欧洲移民，
主要是来自于西班牙和意大利。
那么这导致了阿根廷，尤其是布里诺斯·埃利斯周围的大区，
在血统和城市风貌上极度的去拉美化。
你到了布里诺斯·埃利斯，你感觉就是一个好像欧洲城市那种感觉。
同时，他们在文化上有一种对巴黎或者马德里这种欧洲名城的崇拜。
阿根廷的精英阶级长期将布里诺斯·埃利斯打造成南美的巴黎，
他们在心理上是俯视周围原住民比例比较高的那些国家，
比如玻利维亚、比鲁巴拉圭，
自认为是南美唯一纯正的欧洲文明的活种。
虽说他们觉得这种是我们只是地理上在拉美，
但是我们灵魂上是在欧洲这种傲慢，
可以说是阿根廷在南美洲比较昭黑的一个主要原因。
但有意思的是，阿根廷人他在南美洲有这种欧洲认同，
但是他回到欧洲，尤其是面对他的前宗主国西班牙时，
这种心理平衡就会被打破，
就会呈现出一种非常复杂的，又自大，又自卑这种交織的心理。
那么刚才说到20世纪初西班牙附甲天下，
导致很多西班牙人移民去阿根廷，
然后阿根廷又衰落了之后，遭遇了经济危机之后，
他们的后代又拿着西班牙护照逆留回欧洲，
但是他们回到西班牙，
他们在南美洲营以为傲的欧洲血统，
其实好像并不被承认，
在西班牙人眼里阿根廷人有一个词是有点歧视色彩，
叫做苏达卡，
苏达卡是对南美洲人的一种灭世，
他来自于苏好像是南部的，
然后苏达又是那种出汗的，
所以这种感觉就好像是相下来的，对吧。
这里其实并不是有一个经济上的落差这个词，
不管是有点说欧洲人对南美洲爆发户在文化上的居高零下，
和对南美洲比较穷的人在经济上的腐蚀，
两者都有，
所以说西班牙人可能一方面欣赏阿根廷人的文学，
比如说柏克斯，
或者说在他艺术在足球方面的天才，
但是一方面又觉得阿根廷人那种骄傲自大，
或者很drama，
有种华尔不实，说话又很啰里啰嗦，
又英调，又像意大利人在唱歌那种感觉，
所以对他们的总体印象可能并不是太太好，
那么在阿根廷人面对西班牙的时候，
他绝不像其他一些拉美国家带有那些好像低眉顺眼的那种顺从，
他们有一种老子当年救过你，
就是那时候的粮食援助嘛，
或者说老子祖上比你富有那种傲慢，
但是同时他又面对着西班牙如今作为欧盟成员国的现代化和富足，
深深的感到自己国家衰落的这种痛苦。
所以说阿根廷人，
他不仅没有典型的，
我们刚才说的那种南美的杂种狗情节，
妄自肥波，
反而是恰恰相反，
他们拥有一种自大狂势的落魄贵族的那种，
那种综合针，
有人就给这种心理起了一个名字，
叫做Melancholia sorvebia,。
就是怀旧的忧郁的自大，
那么他不是觉得自己什么都不行，
阿根廷人骨子里觉得自己什么都是世界上最好的，
他们有最好的牛肉，
最好的炭哥，
最漂亮的城市，
世界第一的足球，
马拉多纳和梅西，
他们甚至拥有上帝，
因为上一个教宗、教皇，
方济哥是阿根廷人，
所以说他们不会认为自己是杂种狗，
他们觉得自己是赛籍的劣权，
只是不幸地流落到了拉丁美洲这种小地方，
有一种虎落平洋的落墨，
他们呢，
你说骨子里有没有自卑，
可能还是有，
但是不表现为奴言卑息，
而是表现为对黄金时代的病态的那种怀旧，
甚至于有一点点的受害者妄想，
当国家经济崩溃的时候，
他们不会说因为我们能力不行，
他说因为是政府的腐败，
是你们是外来势力的阴谋，
甚至是上帝对我们这个天才民族的嫉妒，
我这几天跟西班牙人讨论到，
即将到来的这场西班牙跟阿根廷的决赛呢，
很有意思，
他们就是说都认为这场比赛是非常难打的，
但他们并不觉得是因为阿根廷对比西班牙对更强，
他们普遍的观点呢，
就是说阿根廷更有真正的决心，
因为足球对阿根廷人太重要了，
而对西班牙人没有这么重要，
这挺有意思的，
足球是阿根廷现在唯一的救赎与心理平衡器，
为什么世界被夺冠，
或者说马拉多纳，
或者说梅西在西甲，
在欧洲征服整个足球界，
对阿根廷人是如此重要，
因为这是他们唯一能够合法的，
彻底的在宗主国和欧洲人面前，
实现血统压制和文明上的反对，
实现血统压制和文明上的反征服的领域，
在酋长上，
阿根廷天才用他们特有的这种比卡利亚，
就是有一种狡猾，
甚至于小肮脏的这种踢法，
和纯粹的足球上的技巧，
来击败他们口中所谓的欧洲的工业化的足球，
这是对他们在现实当中，
经济上的衰退，
或者说不被欧洲人接纳，
承认的一种最强烈的心理补偿。
在政治摩擦不断，
Rapsot石油公司的危机，
于郑仍然存在，
在两国首脑，
米雷与三切斯在舆论场上，
公然决裂的当下，
足球成为了西班牙和阿根廷，
在大西洋两岸唯一能够保持，
他们这种联系的一个避风港。
无论政府和他们的首脑，
或者说在经济上，
在政治上如何的发生摩擦，
针值,
只要足球还在滚动，
那么那种跨越了殖民历史，
资本掠夺，
和阶级鸿沟的共同叙事，
就永远不会在历史当中被抹去。
那么这个星期天，
就让我们来放下一切的成见，
享受一下斗牛和Tango的碰撞，
来好好地欣赏一下，
这场远远超越了足球的决赛。
就像西班牙人在一场比赛之前，
经常说的，
给尬尼尔美好，
让更强的那支队伍赢吧。
好了,今天的Dodo de España,。
多说的板牙就到这里，
我们下次节目再见，
Hasta luego!。
请不吝点赞、订阅、转发、打赏支持明镜与点点栏目！